tell us why you're at story Expo 2015
today we're at story Expo because we're
looking for storytellers we spent the
last 20 months building a software
program that breaks down story elements
like people places and things as
essentially Lego bricks of storytelling
and it reassigns them or creates an
interactive story game it's like ebook
meets video game and the new use the
name is called one more story games and
the software itself is called story
stylist so stylus being the very first
writing implement of man and it's also
the most high-tech implement these days
so yeah nice and so is this game geared
toward people hoping to write then a
story out of the gate or it's just more
for getting comfortable with words and
building characters things like that you
know what we envision people using it in
a lot of different ways so one way
somebody could use it is to prototype a
film or a video game or a novel and just
use it for their own personal sort of
getting that sense of what that world
looks like or somebody might want to do
a five or ten minute teaser of a web
series or a novel to say hey listen
here's the world that I've created or if
somebody wants to create a saleable game
so maybe it's 30 minutes long and it
gets sold for a dollar we pay them
royalties they can create content that
gets sold through our distribution
channels so there's a lot of different
ways that storytellers can use our
engine and so it's for desktop and
mobile assuming yes so right now the
engine itself story stylus is available
on PCs and we're moving into Mac
development in the next couple of weeks
and so now do you need an aggregator I'm
just thinking of film distribution and
how does it work with games okay so when
you have used the story sets that when
you have used story stylist to create
the your game it gets displayed onto our
web browser well not our web browser
Google's you know what I mean it gets
displayed onto a web browser and also
currently it goes into android tablet
and will be developing for the ipads as
well
also people can play that on multiple
channels and they can also play it on
facebook in a couple of weeks yeah you
said briefly when I we were setting up
that people tend to write a lot about
erotic fiction you talk okay well I
think a lot of people don't realize that
women make up almost fifty percent of
people who gained they might not call
themselves gamers so maybe they're
playing candy crush or farm bill or
those other kind of casual social games
they also like to play games that are
mystery oriented and what's more popular
or romance so romance books are actually
second only to children's books so we're
also open to people who want to write
interactive romance and interactive
erotica we think that because you have
people who love books books books are
about storytelling so why not bring the
casual games and books together and
create interactive story games and
something that's popular like 50 shades
series somebody could create that and do
very well for themselves on our platform
so if I'm understanding this correctly
they're creating a game that becomes
like an app is that right sort of thing
it kind of lives within our app so we're
going to be the digital curators there's
a lot of noise in the games industry
right now you have you know there's so
many games that get published on a daily
basis and the app stores are not
curating that content it's just a flood
so we're developing a community of
reviewers and they're the ones that are
going to say you know what this is
really great this needs a little bit of
tweaking this is not believable so that
when you download our app or go to our
website the content that is there is
curated for you and you could say you
know what I spend my dollar I felt
really good about spending that dollar
what is the average engagement time and
I'm probably not using the right word
but in terms of like you know I'm just
thinking back to video games you could
maybe go to 10 different levels yeah we
envision the most popular web game to be
probably in the 30 minute because people
aren't just like a quick little lunch
bite game you know so they're they're
either playing the game on their lunch
at
or they're playing just as they're
falling asleep at night they don't want
something that's epically long however
if somebody wants to write an epically
long thing they can or better yet they
can use our engine to create serialized
content so maybe in week one it's three
chapters and the story continues and
you're going to say you know what I
really enjoy that I want to continue
that with that content creator now you
said you do stand-up comedy at some
times in a former life time I was a
stand-up comedian so if you get me after
nine o'clock at night with a few drinks
I may change your perspective on cookie
monster forever are there people that do
things that have maybe more a little
more humorous our chasm are there like
comedy based writing we're fairly new so
we don't have a lot of comedic content
on there right now we've got some like
what do we have we have a cyberpunk
mystery that's coming out we have a
couple of your traditional cozy
mysteries so who done it I was trying to
convince our writer to do a romantic
comedy of Romeo and Juliet just to show
people that they could have fun with it
it's a pretty classic story and just
want to have a twist on it you know this
thing where he can never get up the
balcony and she's she doesn't want to be
rescued so I'm looking forward to seeing
what people create with the engine the
idea for this was actually my husband
Blair and Blair has been working in the
games industry for over 14 years so he
worked for Electronic Arts and they
primarily due console games so your Xbox
or Playstation and that and then he
worked for Zynga for a couple of years
and and they were the ones that came out
with farmville so between those two he
really felt like the thing that was
missing was story and we've been so as I
said we spent 20 months developing this
engine after a near-death experience
with him we decided to move back to him
to his hometown and he had not lived
there in 22 years and it was just a
chance for us to say you know what we
don't have any we don't have kids who
down the mortgage let's just do this so
we've managed to raise a quarter of a
million dollars Canadian to build this
with our local students in college
and so we're really excited we have some
really great people coming on board so
aside from the whole writing aspect of
it what would you advise to other people
that are looking to build a creative
startup I think it's fascinating i don't
know if it's different in canada that it
is the u.s. I know there's it's hard
everywhere is it it's okay great we've
got that out of way so you guys both
came to this decision that maybe it
sounds like maybe a lot of things were
stripped away or you had a lot of
epiphanies about what life really meant
to you yeah and then starting from
Ground Zero where you both were saying
let's do this what what were some of the
steps that maybe you could imagine I
think we first of all I've always felt
like the universe has guided us to this
point it's never let us run out of money
which has been a miracle and it really
was Blair had come up with this idea and
I thought okay we can only sign a six
month lease for this office because I
was scared and I think that's natural to
sort of put all of your eggs in that
basket what has worked really well for
us and it's very frustrating at first
because when you're trying to do
something we're trying to wedge
ourselves between the e-book and the
video game community so it's a space
that doesn't really exist it's hard
being pioneers some people that you meet
really get it right off the bat and then
other people they look at you with
glazed over eyes that's been challenging
and also it's challenging trying to
build this in a community that doesn't
have a lot of technology companies or
game company so we're an hour north of
Toronto so what my advice would be to
somebody who wants to take on a creative
startup is make sure that you're in a
community that supports you and find
mentors they don't have to be in your
community we're working with some
amazing mentors all around North America
it's exciting because we're now at that
stage where people can see it and it's
more tangible okay how do you identify
who your preferred mentor is I mean do
you see them online or maybe see an
interview and then say I'm going to send
them an email or a tweet kind of sort of
yeah so I use I use LinkedIn if people
are not using LinkedIn they really need
to be so I'll read an article on maybe
like a
venture capital firm that has invested
in a particular product that's kind of
sort of in our space so I'm going look
and see who are those people with
respect to finding our mentors I had
reached out i did a 8 city tour last
year in 23 days i went to all these
different cities and I thought okay I'm
going to reach out to the people at the
top and see if I can't get meetings
because I'm a woman it was really
amazing to see other women leaders say
yes I'll take the time for you so I met
with see the head of the International
Game Developers Association and she got
to see her prototype last year it's way
better now through that connection she
was able to connect me with other people
in the industry and that just kept going
and going and going and we eventually
found some people I mean I got to have a
skype call with one of the people that
I've admired for like 15 years and they
have made some of the games that my
husband and I love to play so it's
amazing what happens when you ask we've
made some very very daring asks the last
year and they're paying off its you
don't get what you don't ask for from
seeing indie game the movie which was
fantastic and I don't know too much
about the game of the world but just
seeing how I mean they put everything
into this and it was not just money and
time it was just like that's who they
were yeah and is that typical the two of
you I mean it sounds like you you really
this is your passion and you live and
breathe it 24-7 you know I had a career
and a really wonderful coaching practice
that I was building when I decided I
think he needs help because we call him
the hacker on the hustler I go and I
talk to people and I'll tell you we've
been together for 17 years before this
started so we're now just passed in 18
years gradually I love my husband but I
tell you there was a time last December
where I thought I don't know if our
marriage can handle this anymore because
you are working twenty-four/seven with
that person and you put your head down
on the pillow and it's like all you talk
about his work and you forget about the
husband and the wife you forget about
that partner you forget about that love
because you're so
especially in a start-up where you're
constantly worrying about payroll and
god bless hurt the people that we've
worked with they really have they've
made huge sacrifices to do that with us
so it's everybody's in the same boat of
making that sacrifice it's very
stressful very very special I wouldn't
recommend it no well um do you ever take
a break for yourself even if it's a half
hour because if you if and for anybody
who's done something where they're the
soul sort of engine behind it you feel
guilty mm-hmm taking a break in even if
you read a book that sort of gear tort
you feel like I'm playing I'm goofing
off what do you do to kind of have down
time i will say netflix has been my
Savior okay nice we watch a lot of
murder mysteries together we're very
creepy that way we like those like
fantastic Norwegian noir movies and in
series where the most bizarre things
happen and that's our down time I mean
last year we were in the office probably
from 9am to 11 p.m. every night seven
days a week wow that I think that's what
was nearly our undoing now we go home at
five-thirty we'll have dinner and then
we'll probably continue working but
we've taken that time out and we try to
take the weekends off too but that never
happens well there's that saying that
entrepreneurs live like most people
won't so that yeah the what paraphrasing
where where to eventually get to a place
where most people can't how long would
you say I mean if there's probably no
set time limit it sounds like you had to
do that said yes a week 14 where we're
just about to break through the damn oh
great okay you've reached out to some
very incredible influential people
they're taking us very seriously and I
can't wait to be able to say we're
working with them because I think that's
part of the pond it's game over at that
point you know I have enjoyed sorry I
have a little bit of a cough I've
enjoyed working with my husband it's
been amazing to watch and be a leader
I've never seen that part of him before
and but I'm really tired of
bootstrapping bootstrapping where you
just take enough to cover your rent and
the minimum credit card payments because
we put everything into this our entire
lives our entire savings but I don't
regret it and that's interesting that
you say that because i was reading a
book about or excuse me a medium article
about loneliness and entrepreneurs and
because you have such tunnel vision kind
of stuff around you falls apart and it's
not because you mean it too it's just
because you haven't put the attention
yeah so advice for others that are going
through that and also really kind of
asking yourself do you really want it
because this you have to be willing to
give up everything to do this this isn't
entrepreneurship is not a part-time job
it is a full-on commitment and it's
going to take you know all of those
books say it'll take you twice as long
as you think and I was one of those
people no not us not us will be you know
hit all of our deadline no no we we got
tripped up and we lost a little bit of
time and but we just we can we continue
to do it and there's a point where you
worry about where that money is going to
come from but what they say and what I
have found to be true when you were
living your passion people see that
people will walk up to you because they
see that you're engaged you know what
you're talking about you've done your
research the more and more that we have
progressed in the business and gotten
clear about the vision and the product
and all of that and what our gift is to
writers the more people get it so we're
finally at that stage where people are
like yeah we said earlier that some
people are taking you seriously but it
sounds like you took yourselves
seriously for 20 months oh yeah and
that's where the payoff because a lot of
people wouldn't probably put that much
time I you know there was one person in
particular who said how is it that you
file over the place and that's easy I
gave up a car I live in a tiny apartment
I live well below our means I made those
sacrifices because this was more
important to me and I know that in the
long run no matter what happens with the
company
everybody who's done the work will
benefit from it somehow you know whether
they get a better job or this thing
takes off and maybe we'll all be
millionaires that would be really
fantastic but we're all better people
because of the hard work that we've put
into it had Blair not experienced this
like near death experience do you think
this would ever have been even an
inkling to delve into this I think he's
always wanted to build this it's been in
him for a really really long time but I
think having that opportunity to say
listen let's just do what we want for
one year one year where we just go to
the wall and do exactly what we want to
do I was teaching joy and laughter
coaching I teach laughter yoga and it
took a long time for people and Barry to
take that seriously believe it or not
and I loved doing what I was doing and
when you give yourself permission to
follow your passion just even for one
year I think everybody should get to do
that because what happens is and I think
we've all seen it people who go through
their jobs wishing that they weren't
there they're unhappy they're toxic and
that's a sad way to live your life I
mean I'm looking forward to and Blair
always says that i'm looking forward to
cutting that six-figure check to the
first author that hits a big on our
platform because that could happen and
that would be amazing like these
diamonds in the rough that haven't been
discovered that they couldn't get
published couldn't land that screenplay
deal but they created the scheme that
everybody loved so that's what drives us
right I think there's so much pressure
for adults especially at a certain age
to have reached a certain income level
and they only want to associate with
people of that ilk because they feel
like that'll help them and then okay
this is who I am I'm great and I think
it's difficult for people to say I'm
going to cut back how has that been for
the two of you because I know there's a
lot of social pressure even if you go
into the market you feel it it's this
unspoken sort of elephant in the room so
as someone that's you know I'm in the
same boat that's why I yeah yeah well I
have purple hair
for the longest time ever since I left
my conservative job back in 2010 the
first thing I did when I got off the
plane when we moved to San Francisco was
fuchsia cool big streak of fuchsia
because I could and when we moved to
Dallas little old ladies with tisk me I
want to be me and I want to be happy so
I don't care if you make a hundred
thousand a year or ten thousand a year
if you're a good and authentic person I
want to get to know you and I don't
really care about Prada or Gucci or
anything like that I do enjoy flying
first class and I would like to continue
that that if I can but it's not about
those material things don't tell me who
you are as a human being except that
maybe maybe you're able to afford that
or maybe you're sitting behind a
mountain of debt we don't know who
people are based on what lifestyle their
living and I know a lot of unhappy
people with huge mortgages that if they
just you know got a little shack and did
what they loved I would much rather be
that person right i know there was a
website a while back especially when the
recession was in full swing and people
are losing their jobs and it was called
something like thank goodness i dot dot
dot and some of them were thank goodness
i got cancer because then i saw a life
in a whole new way that i wouldn't have
let go of these are all these notions of
success that I had that until I was
facing that sort of this could be it for
me things change so i think that's
interesting and and have you heard of
others that have been in a similar thing
maybe it's not a death sentence maybe
they lost a job maybe they so i think
that you see a lot of amazing resilience
from people you know and that's what got
us through that whole experience was
gratitude so when i do my public
speaking bit so my joy and laughter life
I talk about gratitude you know that day
that he walked off his job saved his
life because the doctors didn't know
what was wrong with him they finally
tested him and it was like whoa you know
he was a couple weeks away from dying
because nobody knew what was wrong with
him so every single day has something to
be thankful for and I think I remember
writing that letter to friends and
family saying right here's the minimum
investment to
help us build this crazy dream and the
money that poured in that week was just
so incredible and there are people that
can support you financially or through
mentorship or just being there and
believing in you I think that's yeah
that's the thing that really keeps you
going and it really needs to be we as a
society need to be focused on gratitude
and really tapping into what matters to
you you know don't go and build a video
game studio or write a script if you
don't love it because your lack of love
will show up and people people don't
want people don't want that it almost
reminds me of the movie life as a house
with kevin kline on if you've seen it
but it's fantastic Oh fantastic and he
reaches that point where he's pushed out
of his job he finds out he has a
terminal illness or or could be and and
then just everything sort of changes up
believe it or not from there reaching
out to people for financial assistance
I'm sure there's a way to do it that's a
little more well-received than others
how did you to approach I know you're in
an interesting situation where it was
different but for those who maybe they
haven't been given that you know you
have this ah well you know it's um I
cashed up my retirement fund when we
moved back to Canada cuz we were in
Texas when he when that happened cash of
my retirement fund and we put all of our
personal savings into making this happen
and for us when it came to asking the
friends and family for the investment in
the company it was a very it was like a
micro business plan here's what we're
doing here's the space in the market
here's the opportunity and quite frankly
I mean so many of them wrote a check
without even seeing a prototype which
really I think spoke to the stability of
our marriage and that they know that we
are solid people that we could carry
this through there's a lot of people who
I think entrepreneurship is really self
advocacy and that's the thing that's
missing amongst artists you know you
could write the best novel in the world
or the best screenplay in the world but
if you don't ever show that to someone
or get feedback
back or a mentorship you're not going to
grow as a beat as a human being how do
you expect for people to root for you if
you're not rooting for yourself so being
the hustler my job is to well to talk up
the company but also to really be the
company's advocate and I think it's a
lot easier to want to give somebody
money or support when they know their
stuff